the death of Queen Elizabeth means
Britain has a new king and a new heir to
the throne a short time ago The Prince
and Princess of Wales William and Kate
view tributes to the queen outside
Sandringham the estate in England where
the royal family usually celebrates
Christmas Holly Williams reports on the
couple's new more prominent role and the
problems it could cause for King Charles
[Music]
when the queen
Charles age 73 got the job he's been
waiting his whole life for
though recent displays of Regal
irritation including with a leaky pen
have some wondering whether the new King
has the grace his mother brought to the
job
[Music]
two other people also got new titles our
new Prince and Princess of Wales William
the Prince of Wales is next in line to
the British throne and the last person
to hold the Princess of Wales title was
Diana two tall elegant women but also
shy thrust into the public View
hi Charles Prince of Wales Charles was
the former Prince of Wales
vestiture in 1969 was a display of
British pomp
more than 50 years later Kate and
William live in a very different age
[Music]
majority of British people support the
monarchy
[Applause]
it's a lucrative tourist attraction
it arguably brings political stability
but these days the public expects value
for money the fact that they take
seriously an Enterprise a school a
hospital a dying person this is a really
important role Hugo Vickers is a royal
commentator who knew the queen for over
five decades what you're describing is
the kind of day-to-day bread and butter
work of of working members of the royal
family yes
Kate and William are much better liked
than the king according to polls just as
Diana was more popular than her husband
which reportedly frustrated Charles so
could their star power be a problem
it shouldn't be I hope it isn't it
should be a benefit but he may not see
it like that because as I say he's been
through this before you think he
shouldn't think about this as a threat
he should see them as an asset he should
a poll taken earlier this year found
that more than 40 percent of people here
thought the child should step aside and
allow William to become King instead
that however is unlikely to happen one
big question is whether in their new
roles William and Kate will be able to
heal the rift with Harry and Megan their
appearances together in recent days
suggest that at the very least they're
making an effort neat
new roles means new Royal
responsibilities that's for sure Holly
Williams in Windsor thank you